make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are picking back up again
with Voltron forever
right so in the first video we covered
this idea that it really kind of took
place in an alternate reality that was
kind of introduced during Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and new Avengers but
what you ended up having here was this
situation where Ultron had managed to
conquer a portion or at least conquer
the earth at some point in the future so
it made it very similar to the events of
the age of Ultron story the difference
here is that Doctor Doom in this time
period seems to exist and basically
secure the Avengers from different
points in time in order to bring them to
a singer' location and have them all
face off right and so what this does is
it picks up with Thor from the past as
well as Jane Foster from seemingly the
present day at the time this story was
written facing off against their version
of Thor from the future right this
version of Thor that operates as a
servant of sorts to Ultron now the funny
thing about this is that when when
Ultron Thor will call him that will
haunt him Ultron fourth when Ultron Thor
faces off against Odin's son he
initially gets the upper hand quite
readily and then actually delivers a
killing blow the issue here is that Odin
son doesn't die now this goes all the
way back to the events of Walt
Simonson's run on Thor and in fact we're
officially and even even a Ewing
actually makes him note of this that
it's in Thor 373 it actually goes back
to issues 361 and 362 and the reason why
is because following his death at the
hands of man God the idea of Thor was to
go to the afterlife to the realm of
Halle secure the soul of Odin and bring
it you know bring it back or at the very
least get it to Valhalla the issue with
this is that over time and over the
course that story because of the fact
that Thor had so brazenly invaded her
realm hella essentially cursed sport in
the sense that he would basically be
immortal but his body would begin to
erode away right so he would experience
all the pains that come with with
mortality that come with aging right his
body we get old his body would
eventually shrivel up his bones would
get brittle different things like that
he wouldn't stay youthful for all
eternity
but he would never be able to die right
and so it's a it's actually probably a
fate worse than death to be honest and
that's what's kind of going on here in
this moment right now Thor you know
Odin's son is effectively immortal and
that's what that's really the one thing
that saves them here because in response
to that you know he basically ends up
using his power and handling it directly
into Ultron Thor and then of course Jane
Foster does the same thing and what this
does is it overloads Ultron Thor he
starts speaking in machine language and
then essentially a kind of AI comes
popping out now when I was when I was
reading this I was actually thinking
about making a
joke because I was like well it's not
really Loki it's younglings Thor
speaking of younglings anything I've
ever had you England's before you guys
know exactly what I'm talking about but
nonetheless you know this basically is
kind of an AI up form of Loki now here's
the here's the issue at this and this is
one of the on running themes that we're
gonna run into you when it comes to
Ultron forever is that there are a lot
of cool things that happen here but
there's not really much explanation as
to how it got that way
the only real exception is what we're
gonna find out with regards to the
Asgardians but as far as Loki the only
real indication were given here is that
Loki's obsession with humanity with with
Midgard and especially Midgard
technology somehow seems to have led to
him becoming a kind of artificial
intelligence and this artificial
intelligence was taken by Ultron and
basically imbued into Thor and that's
how he's been controlling Thor the
entire time now on one side we could
kind of look at this and believe that
it's not actually Loki but on the other
hand were basically told that it is
right that it really is Loki this is the
current form he's in now and he may
evolve from there something along those
lines but essentially this version of
Loki is destroyed pretty quickly by
Odin's son and that's basically it again
it's a it's a cool concept that was one
of the big issues that this story had
there were a lot of really really cool
concepts that nobody really did anything
with and that was what was so irritating
you know so disappointing about it all
but ultimately what we end up doing is
kind of following up with with a few of
these Avengers here and there especially
with James Rhodes who's really not not
necessarily totally destroyed but whose
suit is you know essentially suffering
at the moment as well as a vision you
know who looks like yeast he's in the
process of being overtaken both of them
managed to kind of save the day James
Rhodes chest chest devices counted out
of commission but he still got his beams
on his hands at the same time we've kind
of got Ultron or at least you have a
future vision this corrupted version of
vision with a modern-day vision and you
kind of get this cool little moment
where they sort of improvise in the
sense that like vision and basically
decreasing his density so who becomes
you know lighter and lighter and then
when the other vision does the same
thing James Rhodes comes flying through
and then vision reestablishes his
density and that allows James Rhodes to
kind of snatch her up and get him out
right so it's kind of one step forward
one step back and then one step forward
again you know kind of slingshotting
himself more or less but one of the cool
things you kind of get out of this and
this is something exceedingly important
to keep in mind is the immoral nature of
the Incredible Hulk now al Ewing was the
one who wrote this story uh you know
Ultron forever this is the basis behind
the immortal Hulk story as it goes on
right now in
comics and that was one of the reasons
why I wanted to cover this right that
the Incredible Hulk had kind of been
established over the years in Marvel
Comics that there was a sort of immortal
nature when it came to the Hulk right
the Hulk could never truly die or if he
could his durability was so extreme he
would take a person within it with an
equally extreme level of power to defeat
The Incredible Hulk right so it would
take somebody with like reality warping
abilities or somebody you know somebody
astronomical who could basically break
the Hulk down or kill the Hulk or do it
in such a way to where his body couldn't
heal and recover from the damage that
was sustained right he would just be
dead forever and so the results of this
and the way that Al Ewing really kind of
nip this in the bud and brings in brings
in to frame the notion of the Hulk being
truly immortal is with his decapitation
now I'm not overly familiar with bill
Mantlo or Peter David's run on the
Incredible Hulk and I haven't really
been able to find anything during their
runs from from the least poking around
doing some research that indicates that
like The Incredible Hulk could be
decapitated and banners head would grow
back in its place right I'm really
seeing anything to indicate that I could
have missed it there is a lot of history
to there the cover between those two
guys but the overall gist here is that
the Incredible Hulk with his head being
decapitated banners head kind of grows
out of his chest and we end up learning
this really interesting concept that
banner is really like physically inside
the Hulk that it's not really banner or
turning into the Hulk or at least it
kind of is to a degree but banners still
there and we wouldn't really expect it
to be that way you expect it to be one
of those things where the Incredible
Hulk head is the head of Bruce Banner
The Incredible hoax arms are the arms of
Bruce Banner they're just being mutated
and changed to become larger in size to
match the Incredible Hulk physique you
know to become the Incredible Hulk we
never really consider the possibility or
the idea that in the Incredible Hulk
physical body in there somewhere is
Bruce Banner right like we don't really
consider that I think that was the case
during the events of of space Punisher
but in terms of this is it's a weird
little bit of a revelation it does allow
the Hulk in to continue on and it does
allow Al viewing to kind of prevent the
paradox of the fact that the Incredible
Hulk is the reason why the Avengers came
together and that if the Incredible Hulk
had been destroyed before the Avengers
came together it would keep the Avengers
from existing you know a kind of nips
that paradox in the blood and keeps that
from becoming a problem but well it's
not the biggest thing in the world the
long and short of this is that we kind
of switch over to the various Thor's
that are here now this is kind of cool
because with these three Thor's Thor
from the future the present and the past
this again was coming out of Jason
Aaron's run after god of thunder which
of course came before this but kind of
taking these different points of of Thor
from different points in time and sort
of bringing them together now when they
end up confronting all farther Ultron
this is one thing to understand this is
not Ultron just kind of taking the
ceremonial garb of Odin and that kind of
a thing
this is Ultron with all of Adam's power
Ultron has the odinforce now we're not
really given an explanation how he
killed Odin how he took over Odin or
anything like that where does somebody
kind of told that he basically managed
to do it now most likely what happened
is that Ultron killed while he was in
the Odin sleep because I really kind of
have a difficult time believing that
Ultron could take on Odin and
successfully defeat him the big
interesting takeaway from this though is
that Ultron with all this power has not
really been able to figure out exactly
why it is that he's doing what he's
doing right there are a few things that
we that we learn here that Ultron being
able to do what he's done came by virtue
of him having an over metal body now but
it's essentially the same material that
makes up Thor's hammer but all in all
even with like the odin vision like the
god site the ability to see everything
they kind of have this cosmic awareness
bit Ultron kind of looks inside of
himself and doesn't really understand
the nature of like what it means to want
something he doesn't understand why he's
doing what he's doing right what was the
point of conquering the earth
what comes next why was it revenge was
it just you know his programming a
desire he doesn't really grasp it and
because he doesn't really grasp but he
doesn't know the purpose behind any of
this now the reality is Ultron probably
did it because he's just a dick for the
problem is we don't really find out why
because what you end up getting is Jane
Foster who receives two of the hammers
and then basically uses them both to
kind of rip Ultron out of this current
reality right so basically wipe him from
existence now it is kind of a weird
thing because in Marvel they in a lot of
ways follow the rules of physics when it
comes to matter right that like matter
cannot be created nor destroyed it just
takes a different form matter that makes
up who you are as a human being doesn't
cease to exist when you die right you
basically end up becoming one with the
ground your body breaks down on the elec
Euler level and becomes part of the
world and that's kind of how matter
works you know at least from a from a
physics perspective and Marvel sort of
followed that to a degree and so this
idea of Ultron really is just kind of
him being ripped out of reality or being
dispersed across the cosmos but the
overall gist is that that Ultron is no
longer part of this situation and so
what this does is it really you know
with with this Ultron basically being
removed it allows the forces of James
Rhodes it allows vision and so on and so
forth just our kind of gripping ever
thing up to destroy the main hub of
control that Ultron had going on and
really make their exit once everything
is taken out the issue with this is that
once they're brought back by dr. doom
black widow figures out what exactly is
going on here that by looking around
inside their facility where initially
dr. doom was saying things like well we
can really find the backup hub and so
you know I'll see you guys back and
everything will be okay black widow
basically realizes they were in the
backup the entire time this was all the
scheme of Doctor Doom the scheme of
Doctor Doom was to basically remove
Ultron from the landscape and then in
turn replaced Ultron is the one who was
gonna conquer everything now I know what
kind of seems to throw away but it truly
is the nature of Doctor Doom to do that
the Doctor Doom always tries to find a
way to secure absolute power and that's
exactly what happened here that's what's
so cool about it is that like it follows
part and parcel with Doctor Doom but
here's the issue and this is one of the
big problems that a lot of writers run
into when it comes to the character of
Victor Von Doom he's very hard to write
effectively the only two people that
I've seen who have been able to write
Doctor Doom effectively are Jonathan
Hickman and Christopher Cantwell at
least in the modern era and I mean he'll
Stanley a Jack Kirby of course they
created him so of course they could
write him effectively but honestly it's
been a long long time probably John
burned to because of his run on
Fantastic Four but aside from them
Doctor Doom can be a very difficult
person to write you know he can be a
very difficult person to grasp this so
while this is kind of in character you
know it is a little a little finicky the
way it goes down but it's Doctor Doom
kind of getting carried away with
himself right this idea that Doom kind
of runs it all right he controls
everything now initially he tries to
send the Avengers back in time when he
tries to sum the Avengers back to their
respective time streams but this allows
Thor really both force a moment to kind
of intervene and to use their hammers
and basically spin the characters away
from the time platforms into a different
location right but what it does do is it
allows them to basically maintain their
role here to stay within this time
stream and still have the ability to
correct everything to defeat Doctor Doom
and to essentially free humanity from
his control right so it's a cool notion
it was a cool idea one of these stories
where you end up with a defeat of one
villain and then pick up with another
which I do always kind of enjoy but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explained to make sure you
guys with the sub button to become part
of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]